well the Justice Department is trying to
get to the bottom of how exactly the
Russia hoax the collusion hoax took off
and what role our intelligence agencies
played in promoting it that
investigation is underway now and it's
terrifying to many in Washington Intel
officials aren't used to answering
questions from anyone they don't like it
the national media meanwhile exists to
serve the interests of the powerful and
in particular to protect the Intel
agencies and they of course rushed to
their defense NBC for example gives
former CIA director John Brennan
virtually unlimited airtime dispute
propaganda his latest a conspiracy
theory about how the president can quote
turn off law enforcement and the CIA I
am very concerned about the upcoming
presidential election it's clear that
the Russians interfered to help mr.
Trump in 2016 is mr. Trump turning a
blind eye to that because he doesn't
mind if the Russians involve themselves
again to try to enhance his prospects
for re-election it's it's really quite
unnerving to think that's this president
the Minister Trump can in fact turn off
law enforcement and it tells his
capabilities if they pose a threat to
him personally it's ridiculous they do
allege of course it's got no pushback
whatsoever from the MSNBC a her sitting
on the Senate at the time meanwhile on
the other propaganda channel a CNN
reporter explained to viewers with a
completely straight face that any
oversight of the intelligence agencies
is quote
troubling watch you know this report in
the New York Times that he mentioned
that the Justice Department is now
questioning CIA officers as they
reviewed this Russia investigation which
is it's troubling because you know it's
not you don't do this the CIA kind of
operates in their own world yeah you
just don't do it they operate on their
own they're not in the chain of command
it's no longer a democracy it's
troubling when you ask questions of the
CIA that's not allowed that's the word
from formal news network CNN
unbelievable